oh i'm so happy to be using this source
from gawker.com snap i love it gawker as
you may know is back
for like the second time i think or like
you know it's
uh hulk hogan peter thiel lawsuit gawker
collapses it tries to relaunch it fails
it relaunches again
gawker of course is mostly not
great journalism but i want to use this
source because i find it to be just so
um
funny
gawker says
rachel maddow wards off this info with
disinforming tweet glenn greenwald is
right about this one i love that they're
insulting glenn green all in this they
say something has happened a rare thing
that used to happen all the time but now
arrives roughly every 18 months like a
solar eclipse glenn greenwald has posted
something factually correct and only
minimally annoying specifically
yesterday he tweeted about the rachel
maddow show
rachel maddow tweeted quote patience
overdosing on ivermectin backing up
rural oklahoma hospitals ambulances
quote the scariest one i've heard of and
seen is people coming in with vision
loss he said
glenn greenwald says rolling stone has
now issued a second update that
effectively retracts its false story
that gunshot victims are waiting in er
rooms in oklahoma due to overflow from
ivermectin poisoning yet maddow still
has her tweet up from four days ago
promoting it with no subsequent note
last week the msnbc pundit boosted a
hoax story on ivermectin overdoses
joining a slew of liberal media outlets
in mindlessly digesting the disputed
news and another stern missive about
cover-related information in her rush to
warn viewers of the dangers of
misinformation she did not have time to
fact check oh that's that's a bit
generous
like she ever does come on
unlike several other outlets matto still
hasn't deleted updated or clarified the
error
the original story came from a local nbc
affiliate all right so let's break this
one this one down really quickly a
doctor says he was misquoted he wasn't
saying that all of these hospitals were
overflowing the beds he's saying there
were some sometimes that there were some
congestion and some of it was because
one guy may have taken too much
ivermectin
they ended up issuing the northeastern
health system sequoia ended up issuing a
statement saying the guy doesn't work
for us we have not treated anybody for
ivor macden the story is fake news
and yet
rachel maddow still has it up now here's
what here's what i love hey good job
gawker i don't know why they're
insulting glenn greenwald he's right you
know
sure i guess they're trying to be edgy
but i'll tell you this
if gawker
can come back
and insult people they don't like and
and whatever but still be correct
i welcome it entirely by all means they
can call glenn greenwald every name in
the book that's wonderful if the facts
are true and correct now what i'll say
about this is my friends i have seen
stories and heard anecdotes of people
eating this horse pace stuff
don't do that
because what peop here's the problem
the stuff from the store that people
don't understand it's uh it's it's this
tube is for a 1 250 pound horse
what they're saying with what these with
this doctor saying is not that you know
all ivermectin is horse dewormer like
the media is doing they're saying some
people went to tractor supply
bought this stuff ate a whole tube that
was meant for a 1250 pound horse that's
insane right and then they get sick
because of it
now i don't know exactly what's
happening after the fact they're saying
people get vision loss and there's some
crazy stories but i got to tell you it's
really hard to believe some of the over
over the top stories because of how much
the media's lied how many how much we've
heard from like lying nurses there was
one nurse who was like
someone came in held my hand and said i
wish i had been vaccinated before they
passed and tell his family and then
someone looked up that there was like no
one no one in these age groups who had
died in these hospitals like a lot of
these stories are completely exaggerated
the problem is we got two things going
on
the media is going completely over the
top calling all ivermectin horse
dewormer like when joe rogan says he's
taking it clearly it came from a doctor
and they're conflating that with people
eating horse paste
so then you get people on one side who
are like i tell you this there are
people who just adamantly believe
hyperbolicity is is this gift and it's
great and it and there's there's we have
we don't really have great conclusive we
don't have conclusive data on this right
now we've got some studies
some promising studies some inclusive
studies and a whole lot of me being like
yo if i'm gonna be honest with you i
honestly don't know
brett weinstein can say one thing that's
fine
but we just don't know and so ultimately
what ends up happening is you've got
something that's not fda approved not
fda authorized and there's a lot of
arguments about why that is or isn't but
ultimately i just i defer to the slew of
studies that have conflicting
information
and then you get the culture war in this
saying people who believe in ivermectin
saying the media is lying therefore it
must be true people on the left saying
ivermectin is horse dewormer and mocking
everybody ignoring the actual uh nuance
of the whole situation
and then youtube banning people who dare
talk about it so at this point i'm just
basically like yo i don't even care
anymore like youtube has gone so off the
rails they've they gave crowder a strike
for citing the cdc i don't know how we
navigate this other than just talking
about it and just saying what you know
what we think i mean this this oklahoma
story in particular because we just
wrote a post about that at the sub stack
on inquire and
you know when when you when you just get
the details of the story like if you
read like the you know five sentence
summary of it it doesn't sound
believable right rural oklahoma is being
overwhelmed with gunshot victims
and and those victims cannot get into
the hospitals because so many people are
taking this ivermectin which is a drug
that honestly most people probably have
never even heard of i mean unless you're
really plugged into following all this
but never heard of it
and yet this story not only did it get
tweeted by rachel maddow it got featured
on joy reid's msnbc show the rolling
stone insider it was all over the place
like it was all over the world it's
viral if you go to the hospital's
website now they have a huge splash page
up that says hey look we're taking
people we're not overwhelmed don't worry
about being turned away which is very
important because rural hospitals are a
real asset to those communities you
might have to drive five hours to get to
another hospital because there aren't
that many hospitals in these rural
communities in rural areas so actually
it's kind of a dangerous thing for
people people to believe that you can't
get to the hospital so what i did what i
did is i just called and i sent an email
to the local police and the sheriff and
i asked him like dude what's the story
all about are you guys having a bunch of
gunshot victims what's up uh and the
sheriff in sequoia county in oklahoma
told me no it's a ridiculous story we've
only had we've had one uh shooting
victim who died this year and we had one
other gunshot victim who went to the
hospital he's treated he's fine so
literally you know there's two people
who were shot this entire year in this
county they're not overflowing gunshot
victims and yet why was the media
running this story because it confirmed
a bunch of biases you know you got the
yokel the rednecks all shooting each
other with their guns yes with their
guns and they're all eating horse face
because they're really stupid you know
beautiful so of course it's true we
don't have to call a hospital we have to
call the sheriff i'm just asking whether
it's true how much
so so so is that this this must have
been an extremely rigorous investigation
you must have put a 200 000 budget
behind this i mean how much time did it
take uh to pick up your phone and press
a few digits probably took me you know
between all the emails and calls
probably took me half an hour to figure
this out right
as a freelancer writing on my sub stack
with one other friend who kind of looks
over my stuff right i don't have the
resources of msnbc or rolling stone or
insider or all the places that ran this
story
but what i do have is this idea that
journalists should tell the truth and
get the facts
and that even if people shouldn't be
taking ivermectin unless it's prescribed
by their doctor and it's going to be
prescribed for things besides kobe
because it hasn't been approved for
kovid
we shouldn't lie about whatever
mechanism what it's doing you know you
should never lie i think our top our
utmost
look
i think there's a lot of journalists who
think if tomorrow they told people that
you would explode if you took ira mectin
they would do it because they're
they're doing it they're they're now
putting out a story that says 85 percent
of people
in nigeria
who took ivermectin were sterilized and
that is not
true but you have to understand why they
think this is justified they think
because they have this overall activist
goal of not having people take this drug
because because overall i think the drug
is harmful for you so because of that
fudging facts are not quite getting it
right it's it morally pales in
comparison
you know to what to what might actually
happen in their minds if people take the
drugs so to them
the telos or the the goal of truth has
been supplanted by this larger moral
goal of taking the correct position on
code we're taking the correct position
on on ivermectin and this exact bug of
post-journalism this narrative
journalism has infected so many
different parts of the media industry
right now to where i think we're going
to continue to see stories like this
over and over and over
because again a lot of journalists they
don't care about telling the whole truth
about something they just want to tell
you enough information to achieve
whatever goal there there they want and
that's not very different from what the
nra or the brady campaign do when
they're arguing about gun control or any
other type of activism
let me pull up this tweet i was just
digging around for
so this guy tweets today i learned
ivermectin apparently sterilizes the
majority 85 percent of men that take it
now this guy's not a journalist he's an
activist and there are a bunch of
activists pushing this out and i don't
see journalists pushing this this
narrative out but this just it goes to
show you the the gradient between
activists and journalists and how news
organizations have become activists but
they still won't go too far
so there is a a study that i think
looked at 385 people in nigeria and then
they
reduced it down to like 37 people and
then tracked their sperm counts
it turns out that nine of those people i
guess or whatever the number was were
were unaffected or something so the
overwhelming majority or maybe i don't
know maybe the wrong number i don't know
all you need to know is
it's a study
it is a tiny sample it is inconclusive
activists are sharing it clearly to
smear this medication
here's what you need to understand about
how deep this lie cuts
these tweets are going viral it's this
tweet has 7
500 retweets from this guy
it is it is insane to state this you
want to know why it's insane
the lie that they are pushing is not
about ivermectin and sterilizing people
if what they're claiming is true it
would mean that the world health
organization
has been administering millions of doses
of a drug sterilizing black men in
africa
now that is an insane proposition which
i i think is over the top the world
health organization has ivermectin on
its list of essential medications for
curing river blindness
99 because i looked this up i went to
the world health organization 99 percent
of river uh it's um
uh how do
psoriasis or something anyway 99
are in impoverished
african communities
that's where they're saying we need to
be giving ivermectin specifically for
this parasite now if it was true that
there was a study showing it was
sterilizing these people what do you
think these people would start doing i
mean i'm sorry not even if it was true i
mean it's a horrifying prospect about
the what what these people think the
world health organization is doing which
they're not doing tons of people who are
like rest assured these people are
having healthy families and babies this
is a lie
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you